bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaykum
which is the meaning the greeting of
peace be unto you this is a greeting of
all the messengers of God we're gonna be
talking about the last and final
messenger who was sent to all of mankind
no more messages to come I'm just
bringing you up to speed real quick
Islam is not a new religion brought by
Mohammed a new system way of life but
it's the way of life brought by all the
messengers of God Jesus Moses Abraham
Noah they all call the people to worship
the one God not to worship themselves to
worship angels Saints etc etc now that
you understand this we're going to be
talking about the last and final
messenger who brought the last and final
Testament the living miracle the Quran
he's been come he's come under some
attack texts so this is something that
is not uncommon when someone brings the
truth Jesus brought the true he was a
teacher he never called people to
worship himself Moses when he brought
the truth all of them came under attack
but the honest and sincere people who
looked at their lives and how they live
they saw beyond this they saw that this
was foolishness they saw that no way
that these people were the most humble
and sincere and they brought truth and
proved to show that they were indeed
messengers and that's what we're going
to talk about today so you can see that
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
was the same as Moses was in Jesus and
all the other messengers and he's a
teacher teaching you how to get close to
God with my next guest when we come back
no man Ali count on the Deen show you
don't want to go nowhere we'll be right
back
there's only one Jesus His Messenger no
I did that maybe it maybe it's just to
break the ice I still a male : I can sit
on the lander Cathal thank you for being
with us
good to be here how do you like the sign
it was excellent a little ah very funny
caught me off guard yeah the people
they're getting to see a little bit when
your expression when you saw the big
sign we're welcoming you here to Chicago
and have you been to Chicago before long
time ago long time ago about eight years
ago yeah well definitely we like to have
you back yeah we're coming back and sha
Allah yeah we enjoyed talking with you
and so many people are gonna get to
benefit all over the goggle inshallah so
uh which means God willing see we always
got God in the equation we don't take a
timeout from God never
absolutely absolutely now help us out
there's some sincere people out there
all right and they want to know they
acknowledge that look I don't want to
worship you know a man I don't want to
worship a cow or monkey to Sun them I
want to worship the one who created me
the one Jesus prayed to I want to
worship Him now can we do it on our own
do we need instructors and things that
we want to get good at yes
so these instructors were people who are
teaching us how to get close to God in
the last and final messenger he was the
best instructor at this but there's some
people slandering him there's some
people just saying bad things let's talk
about his life a little bit and kind of
help clear up this junk that people have
put out there absolutely I think the
first thing to understand that you
alluded to in your introduction is the
very concept of a messenger really for
most people accepting accepting God
isn't very difficult to accept that
there's a Creator who created the
heavens in the earth and it's just that
is absolutely merciful etc etc all of
that is actually fairly easy what's very
difficult for human beings to accept
the authority of another human being and
that's a natural tendency people have
you know if for instance if you're
working it's very natural for you to
resent your boss because he's got
authority over you kids want a rebel
against the teacher
he's got authority over them people have
resentment against government cuz got
authority over them so generally
whenever somebody has authority over you
or as commanding authority over you the
the primary instinct is to rebel and say
who are you and so one of the questions
that people have when it comes to
messengers is why do we have to listen
to them I could talk to God directly I
could speak to God on my own terms the
first thing to understand here is we're
talking about a relationship a
relationship between Allah the Lord the
Creator the sustainer of the heavens and
the earth and myself this is the
relationship now in every relationship
there are some terms right so for
instance the analogies I just spoke of
at work there's a relationship between
your boss and yourself you have to show
up at a certain time you have to do
certain kinds of tasks and you know
there's a certain time you can go
there's a certain period of break you
can take etc etc there are terms these
terms are not determined by the employee
they're actually dictated by the boss
similarly parents and children there are
terms in that relationship
similarly in you know in what you own
there are terms set by the owner what
we're trying to say then is if you want
to have a relationship with God you're
not in charge of dictating terms of that
relationship
what does he want from you how does he
want you to live your life how does he
define what's good and bad
how does he want you to spend your day
how does he want you to go to sleep how
does he want you to wake up these
questions they're not up to you and the
moment you start saying well I want a
relationship with God but on my terms
then you haven't you may be accepted the
fact that he's your Creator
maybe you've accepted that but you
haven't accepted that he's your Lord
that he actually has authority over you
now once you acknowledge that he has
authority over you you feel the need you
have to appear sincere you have to feel
the need for him to give you
instructions on how to live alright make
sense and he has to give you
instructions because if and actually he
doesn't have to it's a mercy from him
that he will teach you what you must do
what you must do the other thing to put
some
spective on this again you know simple
analogies help get the point across easy
you have for instance a job and in this
job you have ten tasks you have to do
right your boss tells you here's a list
of instructions one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
you are really good at two of them and
you may be able to do the other eight
but you're not interested in the other
eight so you only those do those two
tasks every day your boss comes in and
checks on you and finds that you've been
actually doing those two things on the
other eight parts of your job
description have completely been ignored
what's going to happen to your job
you're gonna get fired right and if you
you know one excuse maybe I didn't know
the other eight existed right the other
maybe well I only like these two but
these aren't valid excuses because you
will give them these instructions do you
follow so now the question becomes these
instructions where do they come from how
did they get delivered to me there are
people that have crazy answers to that
question they say things like I saw God
in my dream and he told me to do this
this and this or I see God or I feel God
in my heart and he tells me to do this
this in this yeah and this is actually a
delusion this is actually a means of
being self-centered to feel like God
tells you and what really what he tells
you is what you wanted to hear to begin
with here right
so this is actually a very self-centered
and a selfish approach to a relationship
with God and he knows better who are you
kidding you could tell me God talks to
you but you can't fool and you can't
mess around with the all knowledgeable
so you're really lying to yourself and
you have to come to terms with that we
see a lot of this going this is there's
a lot of this going on a lot of people
say well I feel God and God tells me
that I should just have a good time and
party and you know this sort of thing
what really is their own desires being
attributed to God himself right actually
Allah speaks about this in the Quran he
says woman of love illuminates our
analodjica diba who could be more of a
wrongdoer than the one who attributes a
lie against Allah who could be worse off
who could be you know more evil over
wrongdoer than such a person now while
were you daya in an Islam while he was
being called to submit now the question
is submit to what this is really the
question so what Allah does he chooses
certain very special individuals and he
has done
historically and he has chosen these
individuals based on their character
their purity and above all because he
selected them over others this is a las
Decree he chose certain people to
deliver his message to them but you know
this idea of a man delivering a message
to people on behalf of God it sounds
very far-fetched you know to the average
person I mean nowadays obviously if
somebody told you I'm here to tell you
what God told me right and God spoke to
me an angel came to me told me what God
wants me to tell you say this person is
crazy if you study the history of
nations and the messengers in Scripture
in Islamic Scripture even in biblical
scripture you'll find that messengers
were called insane they were called
possessed sometimes when people were
they were really effective and powerful
people would allege that they were
magicians that there were Liars etc etc
but allegations were made the last thing
you want to accept is that actually an
angel does come to him that revelation
does come to him
so this impossible task that these
messengers were put through they would
not stop because they're not you know
there's a difference between a
philosopher and a prophet a philosopher
is obsessed with his own ideas he wants
to impress people with his theory with
his you know with how deep and how
abstract his ideas can get etc etc a
messenger a prophet he's not presenting
his own ideas he's actually on a job
he's been told to present ideas and
ideas so powerful and so radical that
the people around him are actually gonna
call him crazy
you know the philosopher is looking for
praise he's looking for people to say
wow you know people are writing books
about me now and I'm being elevated and
I'm being asked to speak on these
audiences but the messenger is entirely
different he's speaking about something
that is getting him into trouble more
and more every day which is actually a
sign of the truthfulness and the
sincerity and the selflessness of a
messenger and a prophet as opposed to a
philosopher yeah the philosopher has an
agenda for himself and The Messenger has
agenda that is not of itself he's been
given a task and a task sometimes so
difficult we find in the revelation that
was given to muhammad salallahu alaihe
salam the quran we find his task you
would
come so difficult sometimes Allah would
reveal consolation to him to stay firm
and continue delivering the message no
matter how how hard it gets fast my
motto remain committed to what you've
been commanded right
so in in this respect first of all we
have a unique you know appreciation of
messengers in general before we even
talk about Muhammad's life right before
we talk about him we have to have a
unique appreciation of messengers and
how how difficult their task was to
deliver their message great human beings
like no no lay set up my Himalayas on
Abraham as he's called Masada saw time
Moses as he's called these messengers
were incredible people now of them the
final messenger muhammed sallalahu sanim
he is you know 571 ad he's born in the
Arabian Peninsula a completely isolated
desert at the age of 42 cut to cut the
story short at the age of 40 he starts
receiving revelation and immediately his
job is to start delivering this
revelation to people before he got the
revelation what was his character like
what was he known of the people ask will
be former bad boy gone good boy
where would an entrepreneur hang on
there with an icon in the music business
how he attained something that money
that's became a bit of battle will you
fight so every time the successive and
records that I did he left that line was
in the country I couldn't go through it
lived his good life was in the country I
couldn't go through the life that
brought him teach about the perfect
person couldn't identify who our songs
are
sisters get ready you're watching the
teen show take it away what are you
waiting for what are we waiting for
right now what are you waiting for all
these people that come to this club what
are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now when
they're gonna come they're gonna come
along and bring these people lost upon
the water put in our hand the ability to
do your job he was actually a very
popular figure in his community he was
known for his nobility his humility most
of all his truthfulness and his
trustworthiness the Arabs especially the
Arabs of Makkah they in some senses they
were very noble like they would fight to
death for their nobility and their name
and you know the honour of their tribe
and at the out on the other side there
were also people that cheated in
business a lot and swindled each other
and would give each other alone and the
guy who gave the law and would turn
around to ask for the money back and the
other would say well you never gave me
anything yeah you know what I'm saying
so there was a lot of mistrust in
business transactions and in this
chaotic society people would turn with
their most valuable assets and leave
them with Mohammed Salim because they
would know when he cuts it he's going to
keep it it's in a safe place and they're
gonna get it back so he was almost a
safety-deposit for them
in this chaotic criminal kind of society
people absolutely he had such a
reputation that when we find in the
first narration when he called people
the first time he called people the
entire town gathered around it because
they knew when he speaks is going to say
something important he doesn't just
speak out of whim and he whenever he
says something it's a value to us not
like a man who was just committing
crimes and he was mischievous and all of
a sudden he was like reborn he said I
got some tell you this is a person that
he didn't have any flaws or any kind of
problems from the past he didn't have a
rap sheet this is exactly true and the
other thing here is he never made such a
claim before and this is again a
difference between a messenger and a
liar a Liars trying to come up with
something to sell it doesn't sell he
comes up with something else to sell it
doesn't work he comes up with something
else to sell Yeah right
it's kind of like a politician yeah when
this line doesn't work you go to that
line and that line it up until you get
voted in you didn't play these product
he didn't play these polity he was not
interested in the power game at all and
and all of a sudden he comes with a
message and with it sell right away the
people accepted right
no people laughed at it if he's a liar
what would he do then he'd drop it and
go to something else yeah try to impress
people with something else but he is
sticking to this message and he's
committed to this one very difficult
message to communicate to people because
he's not doing it for himself he has
been commanded to do this so now in one
of the things that we know note about
the character of Muhammad his honesty
his integrity his great nobility that is
recognized across the board by all of
them the other thing we have to note is
his commitment I mean a messenger on all
messengers where people of great resolve
Allah actually uses the term Allah Nasim
the people of great resolve the people
of incredible commitment the people of
high caliber of character so it takes a
really a person with really thick skin
really strong you know a commitment to
be able to deliver such a message in the
face of ridicule and persecution now one
of the things we have to note that is a
tremendous mercy of muhammad sallallahu
saw them on you know of all these
allegations that are thrown his way I
want to share with you one of the most
controversial allegations that is put
against our messenger Solar sanam and
Islam generally that your messenger was
a messenger of violence that he that you
know he fought battles and he killed
people and he you know he invaded tribes
etc etc you have a this messenger he's
being accused of being a violent
messenger you know religion preaches
violence and this is one of the big
things right and of course we can't deny
that there are people that misuse the
religion and and manipulated to push
their political agenda or their military
agent or militant agenda sometimes but
here I want to talk about the historical
facts were there actually battles that
he engaged in yes was he actually on the
battlefield fighting and killing for the
sake of Allah yes it's true we don't
deny that we don't hide behind that and
say no he didn't do those things he did
but what I'm trying to present in child
are very briefly is a rationale an
explanation of why what is the wisdom
the first thing we have to understand is
that message he's not the first
messenger messengers came before him and
God Allah calls it his legacy his Sunnah
is called in the Quran is Collison
assume that Allah okay
you see of God you won't find a change
in his legacy the way he does things the
way he deals with Nations when they obey
Him and when they when they obey Him
what benefits they get and when they
disobey him what harm comes to them
there's a there's a standard and there's
no deviation from that standard many
nations thought they came before they
thought they were the exception they'll
get away with it and did they no none of
them got away with it now here's the
thing here's the principle you have a
principle of God that when a messenger
comes to a nation like let's say Noah
Noah comes to a nation and delivers the
message to them convincingly he does his
job there's nothing there's no
shortcoming on his part he did
everything he could to deliver the
message to people answer all of their
questions convincingly and yet the vast
majority of them still did not believe
you know what ends up happening to that
nation that nation gets entirely wiped
out again it's wiped out in its entirety
but I want to paint a picture for you
imagine the flood waters are coming
right these 50-foot tsunamis are coming
and the town didn't believe that it's
coming the town whenever molten or non
honest and I made a peace be upon him
when he said it's coming then we laugh
at him what's that what do you talk
building an ark for Noah's you senile
old man noise warning his people about
yes so it's laughable to people now
imagine that 50-foot tsunami tsunami
came and then right before it crushed
the people it stopped
there's a pause button and then knew of
turns to them hypothetically speaking
says do you believe me now would they
believe at that time oh yeah oh yeah but
does it stop at that point no it's too
late now when the waves come when the
earthquake comes when the fire from the
sky rains when the punishment of Allah
starts now you can't say oh you were
right
I believe it's too late I mean now
that's it that town is going to be
destroyed in its entirety
now Wilson's believe Muhammad is the
final messenger sallallaahu them he's
the final messenger which means if
people disbelieve in him what's going to
happen to that town it's gonna be
destroyed maybe an earthquake maybe a
flood maybe a great Cataclysm but that
town is going to be destroyed but if
that town is destroyed will the message
go further know what why did messengers
come one after another because the
previous nation was completely wiped out
all minority of people believed and then
eventually even their offspring became
deviated and the teachings were lost so
another messenger had to come then
another then another then another so if
the same thing continued with Mohammed
saliva them then what would happen if
the society didn't accept a son what
would happen what would happen is Islam
wouldn't go past a couple of generations
you and I wouldn't be saying speaking of
Islam today there will be no na ilaha
ilallah left so as a special mercy from
Allah as a special mercy now think about
this we say that if Muhammad in fact
sois on I mean he is in fact a Messenger
of Allah and of karesh the Arabs of
Mecca specifically that city they
disobeyed him they disregarded him what
is the legacy of God when a nation
disobeys his messenger they're destroyed
destroyed that's the absolute legacy
there's no exception so there shouldn't
be any exception with this city of
Makkah there should be a punishment but
even then we say we argue that Muhammad
sallallaahu Saddam is the greatest mercy
to humanity so what I'm gonna try to
explain to you is what is usually
considered an attack on Islam is
actually if you believe in the previous
prophets and messengers this is actually
one of the greatest manifestations of
mercy ever to be revealed to any
messenger and let me tell you how the
punishment this time didn't come in the
form of a flood it didn't come in the
form of an earthquake it didn't come in
the form of rain from the sky it didn't
come in any of those forms you know how
it came in it came it came with a
massive legion of followers of The
Messenger Muhammad I said I'm coming to
make peaceful Hajj they're coming to
make the pilgrimage at the house built
by Abraham in the city of Makkah no arms
nothing they're coming to make Hajj no
invading army no pillaging of every home
no rape no killing of children nothing
they're coming to provide you know serve
the rituals but their overwhelming
numbers are such that as they come they
have actually already invaded the city
of Makkah the the enemy forces those who
had rebelled against the messenger have
been conquered with little to no
violence at all tell me in history of a
city that's been invaded without
violence a city that has been invaded
without violence and these people that
were criminals against the messenger
that attend
to kill him that killed and tortured
many of his followers these great war
criminals are there in that city they're
there in that city what what happens to
them are they brought and executed in
public are they punished for what they
did this is the legacy of God after all
those who disbelieve what should happen
to them they should be destroyed our
messenger goes around and says no harm
will come to you today he pardons
everybody he pardons you for everyone
this and then the I outcome but the
punishment the exception is that going
to happen you see the punishment still
going to be there but look at this the
the ayat calm and this is considered the
most violent surah of the Quran Sura
number 9 most misunderstood through to
Toba it comes where Allah says that
basically these people who have
associated partners with Allah that
listen to the clear message of mohammed
salah salem knew the truth in him and
still rejected him these people there
should be no mercy on them but how
should there be no mercy on them you
have four months four months paseo fil
ardi arrabiata ashram go around in the
land for four months and if you want to
hear the word of Allah listen to it and
come to your own conclusions but if you
still don't believe after four months
then you will all be executed that's the
commandment now let's understand does a
nation that this will be its messenger
in this in his lifetime is it supposed
to be executed yes by the punishment
from the sky or the earth cracking open
or whatever else this time it's going to
be executed by at the hands of those who
believe but is it gonna you know when
the punishment starts does it stop this
is a pause button and says you have some
time to think about it now no now
imagine the swords are literally at the
necks of those who disbelieve they're
already there but now God says you know
what pull the sword back give them four
more months even though they rebelled
all this time they have been enemies to
the messenger all this time they have
been war criminals against his followers
they've been torturers and murderers and
pillagers even then right now don't
punish them yet let's make one
additional merciful exception that has
never been made for any other prophet
for months think about it and accept
Islam or fight you'll even get a chance
to fight back or leave the land this has
never had
this option was never given before to a
disbeliever never before and this
actually is a mercy given to our
messenger exceptionally so allaha
incentives right so we have a completely
different perspective and those who are
true to Scripture those the people who
believe in you know the the people uh
that the Old Testament the New Testament
and know of stories of previous prophets
then you understand that when that
punishment came when Moses for example
came down and the people had worshipped
the calf and this is even in the Old
Testament you know the punishment was
that they should all be executed but was
there a time period no no no wait you
could just repent and you can you know
pay for it for months and then if you're
still pretty bad will actually could you
know it didn't happen it was right away
and this is actually even in the Bible
this is even in the Old Testament but
here we have a messenger that was mercy
beyond imagination so the point I'm
trying to make is even in the most
violent of acts that we attribute
against the messenger there's a mercy
the last point I want to share with you
about fighting in general fighting
associated with religion one of the most
common misconceptions about Islam is
that it's only a religion well as a
matter of fact it is a religion and a
constitutional law at the same time it
is two things at the same time and a
religion is based on personal you know
rituals like prayer and the pilgrimage
and fasting Muslims fast right these are
personal things but then Islam also has
constitutional laws the collection of
taxes a form of zakah undertaking from
the DIMM me for example this is a
constitutional kind of law the the
punishment of the murder right or the
punishment of those who commits
fornication etc these are constitutional
laws fighting is also like a military
act it's not an individual thing it's a
military thing it's a constitutional
thing now every nation that has a
constitution does it have in it a
provision to defend itself and its
constitution there is there is that has
there been a part of every civilization
absolutely so when we look at Islam as a
religion and in the modern sense of the
word religion then the fighting doesn't
make any sense but if you look at it as
the constitution of a civilization and
which is if you study history Islam was
and and has been a natural civilization
with its own constitutional law does it
make sense that that civilization have
fighting or an armed
standing army ready to fight and defend
its integrity and its constitutional law
absolutely every nation has the right to
do this and the last comment about this
just a parallel it with the messengers
of the past is fighting the Islam
bringing something new about this issue
of fighting in the path of Allah that's
given to the messenger Mohammed is it
something new or was this there before
was Moses commanded to fight was David
commanded to fight against Goliath has
fighting been mentioned before in those
prophets and messengers that have even
mentioned in the records of the people
of the book is there when is it there
whenever there is a constitutional law
revealed then there is the the provision
to defend that law to make the
misconception clear we don't fight as
individuals so we can't say Muslims are
not violent and you know it's a complete
misinterpretation that we take you know
arms into our own hands and the exact
and violent state right this is for if
there's a state that exists and the law
has been implemented in that state then
in that scenario you you know you defend
that land by means of a standing army
and that's the provision there is a few
more points we're almost out of time now
if somebody doesn't want to accept a
message you know what they want to
continue worshipping a man god they want
to continue to worshiping an idol or the
Sun in the moon what's the leniency now
if they don't want to accept that even
if you give them all the evidences but
they want to worship their desires they
want to make God something convenient in
their mind or they don't even want to
acknowledge God these unbelievers what
is Islam say about this what did it say
during the time of the Prophet peace
it's a very simple statement this occurs
in the Quran will Ali moon ilaha be
Dinoco tell them are you going to teach
allah your religion and look at that
statement allah is issuing a threat to
people who think that they are in a
position to dictate terms of the
relationship between themselves in god
and he turns and says you have the
audacity to teach allah your religion is
that what you're saying you're in a
position to do think about that that
should be enough as a message if you
have a consciousness of God realize
you're not in the position to dictate
you're in the position to take the
instructions and live by them I mean
Allah make us all submissive and put the
urge to submit before our Creator and
our Lord inside of our hearts I mean or
any closing calm
suggestions for those now that have
gotten to hear a little bit about Islam
everything makes sense they're not
confused about the concept of the
creator and the instructions that were
given to mankind it makes sense that God
would send instructions and he would
send instructors those are the prophets
known someone who's like okay you got my
attention
some advice to that person my sincere
advice after you've come to the
conclusion that there is in fact a God
and that you should be in search of
guidance my sincere advice would be to
study the life of Muhammad sallallaahu -
study his life but don't study it from
an author that has written it from the
point of view of attacking him you know
if you want to know what Christianity is
about talk to a Christian if you want to
know what your days am is about don't
talk to a Muslim talk to a Jew if you
want to know what Muhammad's life is
about listen to read a Muslim author
read someone or listen to someone who's
actually a believer of that religion
because then you'll get you know what
they say in English we hear it from the
horse's mouth let the people of a
particular faith speak for themselves
don't let you know your minister or your
preacher or whoever else tell you what
that religion says like if I tell you
something about the Bible or
Christianity don't take my word for it
go study it yourself figure it out for
yourself and when I tell you something
about Islam look it up for yourself but
don't take you know the teachings of one
religion from the mouth of somebody who
doesn't belong to that religion because
they won't present it in a fair way and
that's not intellectually honest Shama
thank you for being with us again I look
forward to having you again next time
he's Sharla Godwin
yep and thank you for sitting tight
through another episode of the Deen show
try to come back every week you got to
hear the message that this man Muhammad
didn't come with anything new he came
with the same way of life that was
taught by all the instructors the
messengers showing you how to get close
to God he didn't call you to worship Him
he didn't call you to worship any of the
other prophets he called you to worship
the one God and he was teaching you how
to get close to God he was indeed the
way the truth and the light just like
during the time of Jesus he was the way
the truth and the light you can get to
God except by his teachings but Jesus
wasn't God Moses wasn't God Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon all of them
he wasn't God so he was indeed a mercy
to the
world teaching us how to be merciful
towards each other towards humanity
towards even the animals look into his
life a little bit further and come back
here every week on the Dean show and
we'll see you next time God willing in
sha allah until then i said i'm alaikum
peace be unto you he created the
universe to him belong the heavens and
the earth everliving he is the first
he's the owner let me eat them his
messengers his creatures of the great
dangers who worship in other than allah
there is none greater